large parts of England will see  pollution saw today parts of the  southwest London the southeast and the  Midlands can expect moderate to high  levels but Wales and the north will be  worse hit with high level 9 out for 10  out of 10 forecast for Doncaster in  South Yorkshire air pollution is  typically caused by emissions from  factories farms or burning of coal and  oil but one of the main contributors is  traffic and it's busy roads in France  which have believed to have been behind  this cloud petrol diesel vehicles emit a  toxic cocktail of pollutants including  carbon monoxide nitrogen dioxide and  particulate matter as well these are  small particles and chemicals which can  travel hundreds of miles in the air now  some of the finer particles are less  than 2.5 micrometers in diameter meaning  they can get deep into your lungs and  potentially your blood stream and have  been linked to a number of serious  health problems medical experts here are  warning people to be on alert